hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled extracellular vesicles
in regenerative medicine this webinar is
part of the cell biology virtual event
and i'm susie valdez of libraries and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation just click
on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits tab
on the top right hand corner of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker dr
benedetta
who's a lottie apologize associate
professor of nephrology
in the department of molecular
biotechnology and health
science university of torino and the
president of the italian society of
extracellular vesicles
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr busa latti thank you for coming you
may now begin your presentation
welcome
hello everyone uh thank you susie for
the nice introduction uh jesus was
saying
i am working at the university of torino
in italy
and that's where i am connected from
so today's presentation
um we mainly focus as we said on
regenerative medicine
and that's briefly the agenda
i will first go through
a presentation on what extracellular
vesicles
are showing you how
they are important for long-distance
communication
i know you had a previous presentation
on a ssl vesicle this morning but for
those who connect just now
for those connecting offline i will just
spend
a small time on that and then i will
switch on the focus of this presentation
stem cell mainly sends a cells
for regeneration and as i am a
nephrologist
i will focus on the kidney as
a typical organ but what i'm saying for
the kidney
is also true for many other organs
and then focus on biodistribution of
vision beaver a focus
on the cargo of these and on the
mechanism involved
and finally i will spend some time on
the possible clinical application of
these some examples of clinical trials
which are the limits and which are the
promises
okay so we all know that um
tissue damage happens and our
organs are in many instances able
to put in place some repair
so we have necrosis of the tissues we
have lots of capillaries
infiltration of inflammatory cells
possible modulation of parasites
that transform into frequency
fibromyalgia
so what happens this process
of repair not always
ends in adaptive repair meaning
we get the organ
repair the end function of the organ
but in some instances we
face a more active repair
so why does it happen
maladaptive repair may happen due to
an excessive damage on the tissue
or loss of the cells that could be
um involved in uh in
repairing could be in charge or
repairing the tissues such as stem cells
or progenitor cells we may lose the
vascularization
of the organs so have a vessel
refraction
cells in essence in many instances
compromises the ability of the organ
to occur and it's very important that
epigenetic pro-fibrotic changes
may happen in those organs
so fibrosis is
considered a disease of cell
reprogramming
that's one example the pericype that we
program into myofibroblasts
so fibrosis is really
the example of maladaptive repair
the final ending of the organ function
and also in patients it's really
important
that to underline that epigenetic
modifications
uh in profitability genes are associated
with fibrosis development so why
i am am i focusing on that
that's very relevant for um
understanding the rationale of using
extracellular vesicles and why
reprogramming
of a whole tissue is really readable
so um
it must be well understood that
uh one single
target it's not enough to
obtain the restoration
of the older function we might target
tgf
for fibrosis we might target other genes
but that's not enough um
clearly to get rid of those
epigenetic changes we really need a
reprogramming of the whole tissue
and so that's why we are
just focusing on extracellular vesicles
because extracellular vesicles
and we i will give you the proof of that
are tiny vesicles
that have a very specific
and peculiar function in modulating
target organ and
mediating exchange of their cargo
namely extracellular rnas
to reprogram the target tissue
and in that obviously stem cell derived
extracellular vesicles have a permanent
role
okay so um what are these extracellular
vesicles
that's the definition that i like very
much um
we need to consider that there are
vastly very small vesicles
in the range of nano nanometers
nano-sized vesicles
they are produced by the secretory
machinery
and they are released in the biological
fluid
to have an effect on multiple
long-distance intercellular
communication
so these electron microscope images
that show you the main pathways of
production
of extracellular vesicles so
extracellular vesicles
is a very general term that comprises
different types of vesicles
released by cells so we mainly
divide them in small and large vesicles
obviously depending on the size but also
in part related to the mechanism of
origin so
vesicles might be released in
in by cells by fusion
of multivesicular bodies when these
vesicles
are present on the surface of the cell
so typically those vesicles present in
the multivesticular bodies
are small and they are called exosomes
vesicles can also be released by budding
on the side
surface typically those vesicles are
larger but that's not
always true and they are mainly called
microvesicles but as a general term
we prefer to call them small and large
vesicles
we have as i was saying information
inside the vesicles proteins
extracellular rna
lipids and
all these multitude of factors
are actively and selectively
compartmentalized within the vesicles
so they resemble the cell of origin
but they are not just the same content
of a normal cytoplasmic
content of a cell and in this really
fundamental paper it was shown that if
we analyze the microrna
present in in vesicles and in cell
they are not absolutely the same they
really
um separate and we have
small and large testosterone vesicles
that even
share different types of
of content
and another important feature of these
vesicles
is the surface
so the ed surface presents
many receptors many molecules that are
necessary
for the targeting of um itself
long distance communication so vesicles
can be internalized within vesicles in
different ways
and the sighted receptor dependent
and decided can be fused with the
membrane
can be endocrine to clarity independent
endocytosis and when they release the
content
they might have their biological effect
so a large number of studies show
evidence that rna
presenting vesicles can be translated
and can be active
that's just an example using um
bicycles with containing her messenger
rna
in a reporter mouse in which gfp
could be um synthetized
after getting the messenger and leaves
and it's clear that after intracellular
intraventricular injection we have
neurons
that are positive for the gfp
and again also many papers demonstrated
the transfer
of specific micrornas to target cells
these adjusting vitro experiments should
increase
in the micrornas
in cells after targeting with
extracellular vesicles containing those
and on the right you can also see
fluorescently labeled
micrornas that enter into cells and the
target
by western blood was shown to be de
based
and obviously after 48 hours the target
was
expressed by the cells so all this
has a relevance has a relevance in
pathology
as it was shown that it is mainly
involved in disease propagation
uh for instance it is from
mice with hypertension that were
administered through healthy mice could
transfer
the same hypertensive feature and that's
a very
from the group of eliot and for
somewhere
but going to regenerative medicine
um the attention
will go at the beginning at least two of
these
from progenitor cells as they really
appear a unique tool
in the control of tissue organ
regeneration
so the beginning was that it is may
recapitulate the effect
of stem cell entirely tissues
and they were doing that displaying long
long term tissue reprogramming
and i invite you to go through these two
seminal papers that were the first
to show the effect of themselves
their ideas
and messengers themselves
are the best example of um
sensors for generative medicine i mean
they are the mostly used in
clinical trials and obviously they have
been the
first as a possible use of
extracellular vesicles in that
application
so from camera cells
derive from different origins bone
marrow was
mainly the first and then adipose issue
has a great interest
uh synovium
umbilical cord and many others and they
have a combined
activity on immune regulation and
possible
multi-lineage differentiation
so these cells release actively
that might be used uh for regenerative
medicine
so these are some electron microscopy
studies
showing the release vesicles
from those cells and you can very easily
see that uh these vesicles on the right
released
are very different in size there are
some smaller ones
some larger one and also the mechanism
is very different
production some are come from the body
as we can see in the right
panel some in the left panel
we can see the arrows showing a
multivesticular body that
fuses them with the surface so
um we must take in consideration
that extracellular vesicles released
from a cell
from a cell source in general
are anterior genius population
and we need to characterize them and
possibly to understand the possible
function population of these and their
nature and their characteristics
with the idea of going on with possible
theoretical applications on all these
so that's another tool that is very
useful in the characterizations super
resolution microscopy
obviously working with such small
degrees
it's very important that the technology
provides
tool to analyze to understand them and
that's happening more and more
um you know with
the progression of knowledge
so we can see here
um uh
500 nanometers up to the one
on on the right is a typical uh 15
58 nanometer um extracellular
and um there are a lot of criteria that
the international society of estacional
vesicles
um with the idea of trying to define
those those vesicles
the expression of markers which are
characteristic of the
cellular vesicles we see here cd63 cd9
cb 81 and alex
also we have the nano view which
is a new instrument um that
allows us to and to analyze
uh the uh surface markers is
the maxplex which is
a beast-based cytoplametric assay
that allows the comparison of multifocus
and so it's very important to show that
those vesicles press
typical exosomal markers and then they
also express
markers of the telogens such as
mesenchymal muscle markers
that we can see here such as cd29 cd 146
cb105
and outside it's another instrument that
allows us
to count the number of particles
in supernatant
and to analyze the mean size
if we also analyze the content of
micrornas of those vesicles
that been performed by several groups
this was one of the first
analysis and that showed quite clearly
that
the processes which modulated by those
micrornas involved the main pathways
of organ development metabolic processes
pronunciation
okay so that's irrational for the
application
of vesicles in models of damage
and i'd like to show you those graphs
which come
from a very first paper
from our group in which a mouse
was subjected to acute kidney injury
and at day one cells
mesenchymal stress and particles
obtained by the same dose of cells
so that those equivalent were injected
and um it's very clear
analyzing the function of the kidney
which is here the creatinine
and the boon that a very rapid
gain of function was obtained
both with vesicles and with cells
and if we also check logic appears
we can see that in mice with aki
um there's a a
great um necrosis
all those pinky elements
are cast that represents necrotic
tubules
with accumulation of proteins and that's
not happening
in administrative with cells with
medical mastermind cells
or with vesicles but if
those vesicles were treated with their
name that's what i would mention but
first
experiment that the effect of the
vesicles was lost
so we also tried to understand where
those cycles were going
after in vivo injection
and we can see that in the heart mice
the vesicles were mainly going into
clean into the liver but in the aki
mouths the kidneys were
a target organ and you can see
also in in the lower panels uh
the different kidneys that were
recovered
24 hours after a cellular vesicle
injection
that are all full of extracellular
vesicles
that's the red color
so that tells us that
after organ damage the vesicles
might accumulate in organs and that
could be possibly due to increasing
[Music]
to damage to the tissue and loss
of the barriers that normally
compromise this limit
but we can also speculate that some
specific
mechanism of targeting might be
occurring
and um here we can also
appreciate how fast is the accumulation
of the vesicles in the organ after
injection
so we see that after 50 minutes we don't
have
much accumulation but after five hours
the organs
are already getting a very high
concentrations
the lever and the spleen
are always targeted by vesicles
so those are the mainly organs in which
the vesicles
are cleaved both in a normal healthy
mouth
and in the aki
so we must take that into consideration
and
we might also imagine some uh
modification of the bicycle that might
prevent
the accumulation of of them
into those organs
and here that's the confirmation just by
monofluorescence of the presence of the
vesicles
in that so we can see here in the
vessels after five minutes
in the upper panel you have vesicles and
after 15 minutes
the vesicles are already present tubular
structures
that appear right here in the right
panel
so that's a more recent
uh work uh showing again a comparison
between the cells and the vesicle which
i think is very
interesting again the model is in peaks
which received the diet and then
a stenosis of a renal artery
to get in four weeks um a profound
damage kidneys so we have fibrosis
to the kidney and we can see that both
vesicles
and the cells affect
the therapeutic effect on limiting
uh the fibrosis of the kidney but
what's very interesting in these pre
iotas could discriminate some peculiar
effects
on the vesicles uh towards
those of the cells the cells
could preferentially ameliorate
vascularization
as we see in the upper panel the number
of vessels
with the mesenchymal thermal cells and
at variance the vesicles
show the preferential effect on tissue
pressurization
and the limitation of apoptosis which is
shown
in in the lower panel on the right
another example of a long
term administration of extracellular
vesicles
comes from this paper
in which a diabetic mouse
was treated in a curative model
after the diabetic onset
the the study waited 28 days before
administration of extracellular vesicles
once a week for four weeks
and again we can see a very nice effect
of the vessel of coming from the
mesenchyma so myself i apologize
this light has some changes
so those were examples if you go to the
literature you will find a large
number of studies showing the effect of
these in acute kidney injury and chronic
kidney disease
those concepts are solid dvds might have
a
regenerative effect although there is
not a consensus
in this lack of injection different
administration
were performed different numbers
even the v are not counted in the same
way
some studies count them in numbers some
others
in microgram some others
in cell equivalence and that's still a
very
big limitation in the field to compare
different
styles
so going a bit more into details
in what's happening in the organs
treated with vesicles
if we compare a by rna set
the presence of the heat map of the
genes and the control in the disease
situation
and in disease situation plastical we
may find
that many genes were
reverted to the normal conditions
and in the case of the diabetic kidneys
those genes were mainly related to the
fibrosis and it's very interesting to
um to note that a very similar effect
was also observed
in liver undergoing fibrosis in a nash
model
so that doesn't seem to be typical for
the kidney but rather a general
mechanism
of reprogramming as i was telling you
so again a lot many
prophy body genes were modulated and
reverted
after three sensationalized
exocellular vesicles
so can we decide which
of the eterogenes natural he is
responsible for their biological
effect that's not easy and
several approaches can be taken one for
possible approach
was to um
was to divide the vesicles into small
and large
by um subsequential
ultracentrifugation so we can see here
10 kbs which are the first going down
which are the large
eb's and one and
kevs that are the ones that
remain in the palace after 100k
g centrifugation
so the comparison
showed that indeed the 100k
was the main responsible for the
winner damage so the repair of the
necrosis and of the castes
was gained mainly using the 100k
fraction rather than the pancake
fraction
and that was very similar to what
obtained with the total is
we understand which other factors
involved in that regeneration if we
compare the two populations
that has been performed in that
[Music]
and a number of micrornas that
you can go and check were identified
that were mainly involved in
proliferative anti-apoptotic
so what's what's the role of those
micrornas are
really they domain
responsible for the biological release
so some study really suggests that
so micrornas have been
cleaved in mesenchymal stem consulting
regenerating georgia
knockout cells and then getting ibs from
the ocean of our cells
you might well know that russia is
involved
in the maturation of
micrornas and then obviously
the extracellular vesicles we contain
the incarnates so going directly to the
results
we can see that the drop shall knock out
these
were not able to revert necrosis
fast and renal function
and in the same way those evs were not
able to reprogram
to get that
mechanism that we were describing uh of
reprogramming the tissue
toward a normal aspect
so that's an analysis of the rna sec
of the tissue showing that the renal
transcriptome
of the mice treated with
these without micrornas
was very similar to that
of of damage aka
mice and variants the tissue
of mice treated with contradicts
was
comparable was
getting almost a similar translator
of that of healthy mass
so is this just what
we can speculate
micrornas are total of the
effect of division no there are for sure
also very important are the factors
among which we recently studied
a protein factor which can be carried
by some vesicles uh present in the urine
so i don't want to make a very long
story about that
but just to give you this example we
obtain vesicles from
urine of normal subjects and
we found out that those vesicles had an
effect that was very similar
to that of mesenchymal stem cellular
disease
in terms of restoring urinal function
in an acute model of damage
and um again that's they stimulated
tubular cell proliferation they limited
apoptosis so what was the mechanism
um it was very interesting for us to
find out that
um extracellular vesicles from urine and
variants of those from
mesenchymal stomach cells contain clover
which is um a factor that is typically
released by the kidney and it's very
important
as an anti-aging and regenerative factor
so that's just the proof that
the kidney is the principal organ
that releases slow tone and mice without
nephronic proto might knock out um
[Music]
for clothes specifically in the kidney
has almost no glottal release and
circulation
so pluto is very interesting as i was
telling you
as it's one of the main factors in our
body
which controls the aging mice without
clothes are really appreciated
and um they present the typical features
of aging like endothelial dysfunction
calcification
atherosclerosis hypertrophy of the
cardiovascular system
and pluto is released in the circulation
as a small cleaved form
and of interest the vesicle from the
urine
carried this soluble small form
of clutter
that's another proof that clothing is
present on the vesicles
going on to analyze the vesicles that
carry the stroke not all the vesicles in
the urine here clutter
but rather a large flash version of them
and um that's a cool expression of
clothes and
a necessarily vesicle marker
analyzed by a super resolution
microscopy
so when we administer
urinary vesicles we found out that
plot which was lost after
the damage was regained in the kidney
fitted with urinary vessels
the same was obtained at
um
messenger rna level and at protein
levels so
possibly party is due to induction of
clutter partly
could be also due to transfer but what's
true
is that urinary cellular vesicles and
variants of melanchol had this
peculiar effect
and vesicle for my step lacked
were knockout for pluto lacked the
regenerative effect
showing that plato was indispensable
in the renal protective effect of those
vesicles
so that's just an example of a protein
factor that could be carried by these
and may exert
a very important therapeutic effect
and obviously these factors can be used
for engineering
inactive vesicles so we engineer
fibroblast tvs
with soluble clutter and
again we got these that were
active as therapeutic effect
so again ev's current lotto
could protect the
kidneys after damage at variance of the
fibroblast tvs
without clutter
okay so i cannot go much in the details
but
um i would like to to save the last
um seven eight minutes
um for the final discussion
on uh which is the therapeutic potential
of those obese so we
we proved mainly for clinical settings
that it is
have really a potential interest
they have the possibility to target
multiple organs
and to reprogram tissue acting with the
synergy of factors
possibly many factors in the content in
the cargo of evs
are doing the job simultaneously and
it's very important that
they may program the tissue they may
target at the same time
different levels different
mechanisms they seem to be
avoiding some typical stem cell
limitation they are
biocompatible they should not have
tumorigenic
and multiversative effect
and they as the stem cells
seem to be non-immunogenic
and we had a first feasibility study
in which extracellular vesicles from
mesenchymal cells
have been administered to one patient in
a compassionate
use the patient had a very
um important graft versus sauce
which was refractory to all therapies
and was treated with mesenchymal stomach
exosomes showing a great improvement
of many of the symptoms of the
um graft versus disease
so that's the kind of diarrhea so
that's um the epithelial damage
uh of intestine uh that's um
loss of some typical endometric
lesions that's loss of uh
some other
typical necrotic
lesions of the gut vessel source
and uh it's not of
um you know um
great
difference the fact that um many
clinical trials
are now um starting using ebs
for organ regeneration so the number
released
if you go on on a clinical trials.gov
is very long here are the
main that i found just yesterday
some of them are recruiting few are
completed
and um obviously
if we go on the condition we might say
that
[Music]
lung diseases and covet 19 related
diseases are among the least
that's not um i mean that's that's quite
obvious in this period
but we have already results from a first
clinical
uh trial um it is two tree
that was um studying the effect
of umbilical chromosome chemist and
surgical
disease in patients
with chronic human disease related to
the diabetic condition
so this trial was ended
some time ago was performed in egypt
and um we had
as you can see from the graph um
quite a stabilization if not saying an
amelioration of the glomerular
filtration rate which is the kidney
function
in the patient's treated with a vesicle
in comparison with patients in the
control group
which had a decline in the function
also the results of the trials of the
first trial
using exosome from bone marrow
mesenchyma stem cells
are now published showing safety the
treatment
[Music]
and again you can go and check out
the paper what i think is very important
uh in this moment to underline
is that there are many
open questions and many points that even
trials that are done in this
extremely specific
and and and peculiar period must follow
and um a letter was also sent to the
others or the people you can
you can go and read that so the
international
society for suspended vesicle and that
for cell
engine therapy underlying the necessity
of um following several criteria
of stringent identity of what
is produced and
given to the patient potency parameters
obviously we still need to address
many potential side effects
we need very strong criteria
for manufacturing in these
and that must be done in gmp
with definition of safety and clinical
pharmacologic
pharmacology and we really still need to
acquire a lot of experience and
knowledge
on that on the um
[Music]
conditions for optimal storage for
optimum optimal dosing
and for the administration of cellular
vesicles
also it's important to
make some consideration on the on the
surface of vesicles we want to
administer
having potency tests we need to consider
that
these from different
subjects might have a strong variability
so aging and young
mesenchymal stomach cells may produce
effective
or non-effective ideas has been shown
in in several pro-clinical data
and also it is from disease
patients such as an obese patients might
have
strong differences in respect to
invest from cells obtaining from normal
patients
so there's still a
long way to go
[Music]
i'd like to also show you this
very nice light coming from
a web ev talk in this period
you can you can
find
[Music]
you can find online this uh ad
talk series and in one of those there
was
also a presentation by dr fujita
of a possible application of autographs
non-stem cell ideas but rather
in this carrying from primary cells so
don't
forget also the primary cells could also
be really important
as therapeutic tools
so i just want to end um
underlined the need of
identity potency definitions
those and administration so we still
need to provide um many
data before we can really go into the
clinic with
safe products
so thank you all for your attention and
thank you to all the people who
contributed to generate
this data
thank you dr abushawati for that
informative presentation
and we will now begin the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's
get started we have several questions
already coming in
dr bruce oblati
why does maladaptive response
occur
so i think i mean in my presentation i
just pointed out
the main possible um
reasons for that
aging and exhaustion of
mechanism cells that could be involved
in repair it's one possibility
so we lose we aging
stem cells that's well known also the
extent of the damage
if we are facing an incredible
uh very um extense damage
we may not be able to repair it
obviously
but also continuous mechanism of damage
like chronic diseases uh mainly
may lead to important maladaptive
mechanisms
and dr visulati why are organs
such as the kidney and liver more
refractory
to stem cell based regenerative
regeneration regenerative techniques
well um i think i mean
stencil based regenerative
techniques can be applied
to those organs um i mean in this right
moment we haven't really
found an effective therapy i have to
admit that
we don't have therapies that work i
would say for
all really all the others the the
um the possible
um you know strategies that have been
approved by fda
for instance that that have been really
proven to be
effective are really really few
so many organs are refractory
and it's well known that stem cells when
they are administered
they don't really go and transform into
the cells
of the organ so they do not regenerate
and
they just produce factors such as
extracellular vesicles secretor
manufacturers that help the organ if
it's possible to repair
thank you doctor lottie and thank you to
our audience members for these great
questions we have time for
two more questions what is ev's
regenerative success for acute
um renal failure and for chronic
renal failure
so um as i was saying we had
um many uh data
from pre-clinical um experiments
and they showed you know effect
both in acute and in chronic obviously
in chronic
a single liver administration
mainly fails to repair we need
multiple administration
i mean all models have it it's it's
standard criteria but
um possibly for chronic
um um you know diseases
chronic kidney disease we we need a
a continuous um administration of
these but um the success
in preclinical uh experiments even you
know in large animals
has been clearly proven and we already
had one child
so that's some hope let's say
thank you so much our final question are
there any environmental
or diet factors that promote the life
of stem cells in a kitten
that would be nice to know
i don't think we i mean we know and we
can answer to that
uh diet factor it's difficult to say
uh for sure i mean uh
stem cells in the kidney are not even
um well despite possibly there are some
progenitor cells
but it's quite elusive so um
we know that those cells proliferate so
um
we need to preserve them not make them
proliferate too much to exhaust their
function but
um i don't know if there's
any any factor that helps that will be
interesting to study
thank you so much and actually we have
one more question that just came in
do messenger cells stem cells
seem to be the most promising for
kidney regeneration and healing and if
not
which do
yeah i mean those were the first studied
and
um yeah the mostly used in clinical
trials so
yeah they appear the most uh promising
but
uh i wouldn't really limit to that uh i
think i mean
we have been studied urinary evs and
many other
groups have been studied uh these from
renal cells so
it could be possibly could be that a
primary um source
of cells which are or vesicles which
come from cells
that are of the whole kidney um
maintain a signature that helps to
uh to restore to
to have a therapeutic effect on the
organ rather than
simply stem cells
which are very generic like
someone cells dr b
thank you again for your time today and
for your important research
thank you this was great before we go i
want to thank our audience
for joining us for today and for their
interesting questions
and any questions that we do not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months
until march of 2021.
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care and stay
healthy
bye everyone